bienvenue à diwan le premier jour l'un
des trente édifice occupé par amazon à
seattle ici tout est démesuré
plus de quarante mille employés 8
millions de pieds carrés de plancher
soit l'équivalent de 12 stades olympe et
une trentaine de restaurants chaque
édifice est conçu de la même façon nous
explique notre guide les cinq premiers
étages sont à aire ouverte des endroits
pour rencontrer un collègue discuter
d'un nouveau projet ou tout simplement
manger une bouchée
puis il ya les véritables bureaux où
travaillent les ingénieurs des espaces
auxquels nous n'avons pas accès ces
pièces renferme les nouveautés de la
compagnie jeff bezos
l'homme derrière amazon est d'avis que
pour bien fonctionner chaque équipe ne
doit pas nécessité plus de deux pizzas
pour nourrir un groupe une question
d'efficacité qui explique la myriade de
petites équipes peu partout et
l'immensité des lieux en fait difficile
de rater amazon lorsque vous êtes assis
atone et ce géant est situé en plein
coeur du centre ville de seattle
un concept crucial pour jeff bezos ce
qu'ils cherchent des employés branche
est tourné vers l'innovation et qui
veulent vivre dans une ville qui vibre
un choix qui a transformé la ville admet
cet analyste de l'industrie tu es le
quartier avant l'arrivée du mastodonte
et est en décrépitude entrepôt et
commerces fermaient leurs portes
aujourd'hui il est devenu la mecque de
la modernité par les onze chefs et
gitana qu'à l'importance d' amazon a
incité son entreprise à ouvrir 16
restaurants tout autour
résultat des milliers d'employés
d'amazon visite y salle à manger chaque
jour et l'impact dans la ville ne
s'arrête pas là plus de deux cent mille
nuitées par année dans les hôtels reliés
au géant du commerce en ligne
cinquante mille emplois créés dans
l'industrie de la construction en cinq
ans et 38 milliards de dollars de
retombées problème le salaire moyen ici
à la maison c'est plus de 100 millions $
et nous avons employé de tous les parts
de planète
nous avons plus de 50 nationalités a ici
des spécialistes du marketing comme des
ingénieurs des administrateurs des
comptables des avocats
mais accueillir une telle entreprise ne
se fait pas sans heurts ce que l'on a
réalisé explique todd c'est que les
petites entreprises n'arrivent plus à
trouver du personnel qualifié
amazon cannibalise tout autour de lui
il met aussi une pression énorme sur les
infrastructures réseaux de transports en
commun réseau routier transporter 40 ou
50 mille employés nécessite des
ajustements de taille l'arrivée de tous
ces professionnels fait aussi grimper le
prix des résidences en flèche il a
doublé ici en disant et 1.25 bergues
malgré ces inconvénients les experts
s'entendent pour dire que la ville qui
remportera le deuxième siège social sera
extrêmement choyé qu'il s'agira de l'un
des plus importants investissements
privés dans une région de l'histoire
sans compter que chaque poste chez
amazon devrait créer cinq emplois
indirects comme il l'a fait si attend
ici van kote radio canada s'y attend
[Musique]